ladies and gentlemen boys and girls we
have new merch out yes we have a new
merch line which we're in this episode
so we're gonna show it off but if you
want to get your hands on some of them
go to trashtaste.co that's trashtaste.co
enjoy the episode giant squids too oh
yeah yeah those are cool though yo don't
tell Japan about those guys
hello and welcome to another episode of
the trash tease I apparently I've
forgotten how to speak okay let me do
that again hello and welcome to another
episode of the trash taste podcast I'm
your host for today Gant with me once
again other boys and uh treats for you
guys because this is another timely
episode because oh my God we have just
gotten back from La for our ax trip and
uh Joey you've just got back from
Vietnam well actually I don't know how
long you were in Vietnam for I was in
Vietnam for 15 days 15 days yeah two
weeks roughly wow so sorry if you missed
me at ax I was busy celebrating my
mother's number one question was where
the [__] is Joey yeah why do they
abandon you oh I just don't love you
sorry I abandoned the boys because I
love my mum more than the boys
I've chosen trash taste over my family
time and now suddenly you want to sit on
your family yeah mom is slightly above
the boy I can't believe it Joe I thought
we were brothers Joey I thought we were
fam nah yeah but uh yeah went to Vienna
for two weeks and it was hot as balls
like hotter than here like it is now it
is as you know summer in Japan and our
AC unit chose today to uh start being
broken so we are here trying to wear a
trash bag you're only gonna see Garner
wearing these for a little well okay so
you clearly want to take them off so
like you show off the jackets okay the
viewers I'm sure these are available
right now if you're watching this as it
comes out yes yes they're only available
for like two more weeks so get them now
while you can yeah because once again
I'll show them I'm gonna reveal that I'm
wearing these [__] [__] it's summer
okay but we got jackets
we were rocking this a lot yeah
dude so many people are wearing this one
look at that
upcoming winter
I I am so happy because I finally
convinced uh the team to make a denim
jacket this is this is the most gone
thing I've ever seen in my life but yeah
it looks so natural like you that's
clean as [__] look at that that's nice
dude the embroidery is so [__] [__]
it's very nice we went for a Japanese
newsprint kind of style for this ax but
I know that a lot of people were
confused whether we were selling this
online we are selling this online at uh
denim jacket here and the hoodie there
as well yeah other t-shirts too t-shirts
underneath as well yeah and get it
because this is the [__] sick merch
drops yeah yeah links in the description
get it now yeah we saw it out at ax so
you know we're opening up online sales
so there you go you got two more weeks
to get these while you can but uh we're
gonna do a jean jacket again frankly I I
hope so
really like this one okay it's really
horny so I'm gonna take this off right
now yeah beautiful T-shirt oh Joey nice
t-shirt too thanks man is there
something on the back I think so uh
okay there's that one doesn't I can't
remember if there wasn't enough all
right yeah
but yeah how was uh how's Vietnam Joe
um yeah so as I was saying uh it's hot
as hell in Japan right now I mean we've
talked about you know summer here we've
done entire episodes
crushing the Japanese summaries I didn't
know like there was like a dark souls
level of hotness until I went to Vietnam
in the middle of June welcome to
Southeast Asia like I wasn't sweating I
was perspiring like yeah it was
inspiring
person
it was raining perspiring it was raining
from my face it was disgusting like I'm
pretty sure I made like my own cloud
system just because of just how [__]
sweaty it was you should take a Nick
card avocado he's got a little water
weight
dude it was weird like I ate okay so
obviously I'm on vacation right that's
my whole family's on vacation so when
you're on vacation mode you don't care
about what you eat all right yeah right
so you just go ham on every all the food
right because I wanted to have the most
it was my first time Vietnam I wanted to
get all of the authentic Vietnamese food
right yeah some of it's healthy of
course course then some of it isn't
whilst I was like [__] it I'll just get
everything and somehow even though I
haven't gorged myself that much in I'd
say at least the past three or four
months I somehow still lost weight
you're probably walking around because
of you know I mean we went on some hikes
but also I think just during the day I'm
sweating like 10 liters so like legit
like nicocado if you want to lose some
weight bro
you want to lose that water weight bro
you'll lose it immediately we were in
America like I noticed that like I was
walking more on average in America than
I was when I'm here in Japan yeah it
doesn't make any [__] sense
well because I I we we were doing houses
are big enough
well yeah yeah that's right laundry's
house is huge yeah uh everything I was
doing involved me being standing up and
walking around even if it's just like a
little bit like I was just doing a lot
more walking like in Japan when I'm
streaming I'll sit there and I'll look
and I'll be like wow oh
what happens when you touch grass you
know it's like it's like if you just sit
in all day
yeah yeah I was also we were just doing
stuff I was doing stuff every single day
so I was always walking every day even
if I was ubering there I would then had
to walk because like in America you know
uh it's actually you still have to walk
a lot because you're like oh the parking
lot is [__] 900 meters long and
you're like oh [__] okay well that's
that's 500 steps right there you know
it's like this they sneak it in you
don't realize it everything actually is
[__] spread out so goddamn much I
think I think the conclusion from this
is that you need to be walking more
while you're in Japan no no because I I
think the conclusion you can take from
this is that Connor walks more in
America but he is a very small
percentage of people the people that
stream yeah that work from home and
stream all day and do not go outside if
you go to America then you end up
walking more unless you're in America
and you stream all day as well so I'm
actively trying to not go outside right
now and if I do it's like the taxi is
the buffer like I like I'm getting in
that I'm going because I don't want to
be outside it sucks oh you would have
hated it in Vietnam yeah I would have I
would have been the hottest day we had
was when I was in Saigon and it was like
46 degrees [__] that and that's not
including the humidity I'm going to
Thailand
oh my God it was like I never felt like
my life was in danger from heat yeah
until I went to Vietnam like just
stepping outside not even in the sun in
the shade right because the humidity
here is bad but somehow Vietnam was just
like we can get hotter when it comes to
me so like it there was literally no
difference between standing in the Sun
and standing in the chair you just felt
like there was a heater attached to your
face at all times and it was disgusting
oh I'm surprised because normally like
for Thailand at least uh July period is
actually like one of the cooler periods
because it's rainless it's rainy season
in Thailand yeah uh like the hottest
seasons are kind of actually maybe maybe
I'm maybe even think of May but like
there is a definite hot periods but the
best period to go to like southeast Asia
is kind of around like February kind of
like period yeah well I mean when we
went to Thailand in January it was great
yeah yeah that was like that was perfect
it was like actually like nice you could
like breathe and yeah
yeah exactly yeah right but yeah
California was great weather too though
yeah yeah California we did not we
didn't have a heat wave this time uh
there was no kind of like it's hot but
then you go in shade and you're like oh
yeah it's uh it's bearable yeah it's
assurable but uh the important the
question is did you rent a moped see I
really wanted to because I'd heard about
God's stories of like riding in a moped
almost dying and I was like I want that
near-death experience and I tried but
because I was with my family I asked my
mom
ah and she was like well you know it's
my birthday
and I don't want you to die on my
birthday
you did that you did the wrong thing you
should have asked for forgiveness no
but like you know I was really down my
dad was like kind of down uh my sister
and my mom were just like no I don't
want to die so unfortunately I couldn't
but hopefully next time I go to the boys
trip boys trip if we go back yeah if we
go back to Vietnam in the summer that's
what I'm I'm hearing I'm drunk now oh my
god dude you would have been like every
time every time I walked past like uh
foreigners were in uh Vietnam because
there was like a surprising amount of
foreigners during that time of year I
was like I thought for sure everyone was
going to try and avoid the summer heat
but yeah there was a lot of people there
wasn't it like don't they get [__] tons
of tourists because it's super cheap
well yeah that too but yeah but it's
cheap all year round right so you'd
think you'd try and aim for like you
know January February time like people
like normally like to take some holidays
you know like Europe it's like a culture
of going home in the summer yeah it's
like Summer's the time oh my God yeah
but every time I started European
tourists and they look like they wanted
to kill themselves they were just like
it never gets hot here yeah it never
gets hot at home like this I can't
imagine them surviving Southeast Asian
Summers like that oh my God they will
not survived yeah it was it was bad but
other than the heat everything else was
[__] amazing I went to uh what is
considered to be the best ban me
restaurant or I guess place in all of
Vietnam is this place in Korean that uh
Anthem is just like the they're like the
sandwiches like sandwiches Vietnamese
sandwiches but apparently this one is
hot the highest rated or the best in all
of Vietnam because Anthony Bourdain went
to it and uh yes
opinion
I found that really weird because I was
like when we were at the hotel in Hoi An
and I was like oh we really want to get
some like good Vietnamese food where do
you recommend there's four Vietnamese
like guy at the front desk was just like
have you ever heard of and Anthony
Bourdain he he recommended this place in
Hoi An I wonder if they were like hey my
cousin says this one's the best yeah I
don't know who's that white guy yeah I
was expecting like a super local place
right but it's just like no go to this
place that the white man said it was
good oh no man I've seen how Gordon
Ramsay Cooks apart Thai man
I'm seeing that video when I'm
okay highly
like this so there's a video where
Gordon Ramsay goes to this like Thai
restaurant and it Cooks the pad thai and
the chefs and I I remember the first
time watching it I've never had such an
uncle Rogers kind of like reaction to
someone cooking my contacts I'm like
this is not Pad Thai and thank God the
Thai Chef who was you know very politely
uh very politely said this is not how uh
we may play I don't know
he he tried to politely work and to be
to be fair to Gordon Ramsay he did very
much you know take his advice on how to
cook apart side but you know I if
Anthony Bourdain says this is the best
ban me restaurant in Vietnam I'm gonna
call sauce on that yeah it was also
really weird because like because I saw
the clip of like the actual episode
where he actually went there you know
just the double check this was the right
place yeah apparently I didn't have to
because the moment I got to this place
in front of it there's this huge like A3
[__] poster of Anthony Bourdain just
like deep throating upon me and right
next to it in this like curse of text it
was it was a quote from Anthony Bourdain
and it did us and it said the best
baguette I've ever had
and I thought has Anthony Bourdain never
been to France
has he never been to Europe because I'm
not too sure that was a mistranslation
they were like they were like I think he
said baguette actually yeah no no yeah
no maybe Bond me in Vietnamese equals
baguette I don't know but I was like
okay you know what hold on I'll I'll
take the benefit of that I'll go in to
be fair it was the best bombing I've
ever had yeah and we went to a couple of
places in Vietnam as well and obviously
outside of Vietnam and I would say you
know what he wasn't fully capping but
I'm sure some Vietnamese you know people
are going to be like no no that one's
overrated go to this one it's definitely
got to be something people when
sometimes people come to Japan and then
like they've been here like four or five
times they'll be like dude I know like
the best spot to eat and I'm like okay
tell me and then they'll just send me
something and it'll be like a really
well-known restaurant
it'll be like something that everyone
knows about that is just pretty okay and
it's like there's another [__] this
is not a find yeah this is you went on
Google and typed in sushi restaurants
yeah I mean every actually for every
Ramen pick I see on Twitter is each
round which is fine you can get it
around I mean I like itchron it's good
but it's like it's like the McDonald's
Adventure right yeah it's great it's
better I like it tastes good we've
tastes like a million times but yeah
it's I'm very skeptical when somebody
who visits a place like this is the best
place here it's like you don't know [__]
yeah my favorite one though and that was
the other thing I loved about Vietnam is
uh and obviously this gets memes a lot
uh in like Western countries with that
have Vietnamese restaurants it's just
like some of them just have the best
[__] names for restaurants I went to
this restaurant
in Sapa when we did this like three-day
hike in the mountains
um beautiful place definitely go but uh
there was just this restaurant right
next to our hotel just called yummy
restaurant
was a yummy restaurant and I kid you not
it was yummy I mean actually no problem
here yeah yeah yeah
all right I mean you weren't lying this
was a yummy restaurant it was just very
weird though when you look up on Google
and the first thing that comes up is
yummy restaurant well I feel like you
know I've seen this quite a lot in uh
Thailand at least where sometimes if you
just want to make your restaurant stand
out uh you know like you know if you
open a Thai restaurant here in you know
a foreign country you want to like a
Thai name to it uh but over there if you
just put like a [__] English name
that's what makes it stand out you know
we don't want the traditional Thai name
we want like the foreign name the wacky
foreign
I remember seeing all those weird
statues like they would have like
one-to-one size statues of like Thor
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like why
don't you
just have like a normal ass restaurant
but in front of it it's just like just
dudes like like Captain America being
rammed by like Tony Stark or something
a one-to-one statue so every [__]
Google pick of the restaurant is just a
statue of like a copyrighted Disney
character just being raw dogged and so
then that way if everyone want to post
about your place and people are gonna go
there and all I have to do is commission
a statue of like maybe like I don't know
well just like the most cursed [__]
imaginable it's like super it's like
Mario like on his knees in front of
Luigi yeah and he's like oh I'm doing
his pants and his one-to-one scale and
like that's the picture that everyone's
commit like making out with Mickey Mouse
yeah like Mario Sonic Mario
one-to-one statue and like you can't
avoid it because people are gonna see it
and post about it sure and and you can
do it in these places because nobody's
crank clapping down these copyrighted
yeah there's something similar happened
when I was in Hoi An uh there was this
[__] bar that was like themed around
Mr Bean oh was he making out with
someone no idea no I went about two
legit to the gym when it was like the
entire ball like all the drinks all the
food was themed around Mr Bean and I'm
like I don't think this got the all
clear from like yeah that's not enough
yeah you need something like absolutely
out there but that also won't get a shut
down because I assume there's got to be
a limit right yeah but I mean you still
want people to come to your restaurant
you know you don't want to be having
like a nice little meal and then you
just look and it's just Mario and Sonic
making out and you're just like I don't
know man I don't know
so it's like it's like Mario Sonic
making out in front and then you get in
and then on the roof it's like two
Spidermans in that one Spider-Man meme
where he's like slapping his ass in the
bed but on the roof and the whole
restaurant is just absolutely [__]
copyright characters just going at it
and that way everyone wants to come in
and see what's going on and they sit
down there and when I charge like I rip
off all the tourists as well I think
this is a great idea yeah another thing
as well that I noticed about it is that
um like you know the concept of happy
hour right yeah like a bar yeah right
like normally what what would what would
you say is like the average time of
unhappy hour they scam you it's like 3
P.M on a Monday yeah but 3 P.M like
usually right when you go to like any
Western Country happy hours usually I
don't know between maybe like four and
seven maybe five and seven it's a couple
never happy hour it's never seven so
Seven's two not generous it stops at
like six yeah I saw a restaurant in
Saigon dead ass right in front of the
store big sign happy hour 9 A.M to 8 p.m
and I'm like when is it not happening at
that point every hour is happy yeah just
say we have free we have free drinks
we're just coming they're just happy how
happy are you we are happy during these
hours there's not a lot of work because
we're open yeah they misunderstood the
concept of Happiness they clearly didn't
know what happy hour happy hour means
we're open right it's actually stressful
for us after this time so please
actually be more considerate after this
but I went in and sure enough the guy
was like yeah uh buy two get one free
that's fine and we were there in like
the 12. and I was like how how are you
surviving as as a business well I mean
uh I mean if people are coming there at
like 9 A.M you must be doing something
right yeah
what was your favorite place in Vietnam
then oh geez that's hard I probably have
to say Sapa um it's like right on the
northern border of Vietnam
um it's called it's called the city in
the clouds because it's like the
elevation of this entire Village is like
a thousand meters up
um and it's like there's just these like
clouds rolling over the hills it looks
like a [__] Princess Mononoke Scene
It was so sick um and we went on this
like two-day hike down into the valley
to like go to all of the um indigenous
Vietnamese Villages
um and like kind of went around there
that was like [__] amazing like that
if you like hiking like for sure go
there
um I hate hiking though and hiking in
South Africa
Asia we were like Dennis in the jungle
I've done that once and I think I almost
got a heat stroke because I'm like how
do I how do I cool off I can't I can't
splash water on myself because that's
like the atmosphere is already doing
yeah so I'm like it actually sounds like
my
but then on the second day it was like
raining quite a bit and I was just like
oh thank God oh yeah thank you yeah I I
love the rain in Southeast Asia because
you're like you can literally feel like
the climate like going down a few
degrees yeah you're like oh my God but
but the problem was it was a
double-edged sword because it was like I
I was calling down from the rain but the
this entire hike we were in in the
jungle is like mud so I'm basically like
ankle or like almost like yeah ankle
deep in mud I wore my vessels and uh you
know those survive so I definitely gave
them like the best [__] promo they've
ever had because I came out of this hike
like my [__] shoes were muddy as [__]
still good it's not a single drop on my
socks literally sounds like my nightmare
yeah it was fantastic though like it was
definitely a hard hike but like just
getting to see this like insane looking
like views yeah it just didn't look real
but it was yeah [__] amazing yeah
yeah maybe I don't recommend for people
who don't like I love hiking so I enjoy
the [__] out of it but yeah I I've
realized especially when uh when I went
on the ski trip I was like oh so skins
kind of like you get all the advantages
of hiking except yeah actually hiking
why people love it yeah I was like yo
why yeah yeah white people are on to
something man
chill you can drink they mean Max hiking
yeah you you have the fun part which is
just going down and then you can drink
in between get great views they just
build a device just to like get like cut
the hiking out what damn if only it
wasn't so expensive yeah exactly right
oh this is this is it yeah hiking is
great if it's pay to win you know if
it's pay to win if it's pay to win like
for me it's like hiking is notification
so hearing that this is a vacation I'd
be like no my head I'm like this is like
an activity and I wouldn't want to do it
as of it I don't know my brain's weird
like that I don't know I I think I think
for me like hiking can definitely be uh
like a roll because you know it wasn't
like we were like speed running this
hike or anything and it wasn't like that
long of a hike either I think we did
maybe like 10 15 kilometers yeah um
which is like nothing really but you can
get that done like half a day
um but I think like for me it was just
cool because you would never be able to
see these like traditional Villages or
like know anything about it like our
guide that took us was one of the
members of this like indigenous
Vietnamese Village and she just like
knew all the [__] shortcuts and [__]
and it was just so cool to just be able
to see firsthand these like insane
environments that just like look
straight out of a video game yeah um so
like yeah it was tiring but is that what
you like about hiking the views yeah I
think like just if you're hiking I would
say like hiking in just like a forest
that you can't see the views from or
like you know if you don't hike to like
say the top of a mountain or whatever
then it's like okay yeah this is fine or
whatever but I think what I really enjoy
about hiking is just like when you pull
out of the really dense foresty areas
into an open area and you get to see
like where you got to and yeah the the
all the views and [__] like that's
really gratifying for me it's just like
oh I [__] did it like I got to this
place and see this thing that I can only
see
if I if only I had like gone through
this like trick right yeah because like
all these places were completely
inaccessible by anything other than the
foot right so just to be able to say
that like you know I got to those places
and got to see it for myself as like I
don't know I find that really cool and
gratifying yeah I think that's why I
really like you know just like climbing
mountains and stuff as well going on
long walks and [__] yeah that's the part
I also like that's the only part I like
which is the views I don't like but to
say like I don't enjoy getting from
point A to point B in fact I [__]
despise it all the time you know like
like I'm not calling out hikers I get
the feeling of like holy [__] this is a
massive view but I am that [__]
who's going to complain from like like
the bottom to the top that's the British
I'm like I mean I get the views but I'm
not going to say I enjoy the experience
of hiking you know I don't know I like
especially when it's like a muddy Trail
or like you know an off-road Trail yeah
I really enjoyed like the challenge
aspect of it just being like oh cool got
through that and you know I didn't die
so it's like I don't know there's maybe
that's just me I don't know but that's
how I feel when I survive L.A I'm like
I made it to the next block without
dying oh yeah also I don't know I I
guess like another thing is like you
said you said muddy stuff I don't I
I I think I've kind of realized I
[__] hate muddy things or mud or
getting dirty I don't know it's it's
it's a weird thing
um
I like EXO for me I like a very good
distinction like I am happy to get muddy
and dirty when I am I'm planning to do
that yeah but I don't like it when I go
to a place and it's like you're [__]
dirty and there's [__] everywhere and
like a like a hoarder's house it's like
that that kind of dirt or kind of stuff
like that I'm like that is am I I like
my worst like you don't like you don't
like when something is dirty in an
environment
but if you tell me hey Connor you gotta
go and [__] hike in the mud for three
days and be gross I'm like all right
cool yeah yeah I think I I only like
yeah I'm the same thing like I'm not
gonna [__] be walking down the street
in Tokyo and like be happy if someone
throws mod at me like that it's like
that's like I I don't associate like
being muddy is the same part of my brain
that like uh that thinks like stuff so
dirty right it's a different
and all that kind of stuff and getting
dirty in that sense is is very different
in my head to how I view like
traditional like natural dirty well yeah
like messy stuff or kind of like you go
to a place like uh I don't know
sometimes you go to a place you're like
man I do I can't [__] comfortably in
this toilet it's not clean like yeah
stuff like that I think that's the big
reason why I just never went camping a
lot in the UK because I always
Associated it with you know I now that
I've been camping at other places I'm
like oh camping's so much fun but in the
UK it's just like you go out and it's
just like the floor is just muddy and
you just like especially if it's been
raining and then you just gotta Trek out
and you just never like I'm just never
comfortable you know yeah I get that
yeah that sounds I mean I love camping
but if you told me to go camping in the
UK I'd probably be like
it's cold yeah yeah no [__] that yeah if
I'm gonna go hiking normally I like a
trail I've never done like off-trail
hiking or anything like that so maybe
that might be fun because I'm the same
way if I if I know if I have time sounds
like mentally prepared to be like oh
you're just you're gonna get like down
and dirty and you're just gonna you know
[__] yourself up then I'm like okay at
least I have like preparation for that
yeah but if I just want to chill I'm
just like I'm I'm in like chill mode do
not do not disturb chill mode right now
yeah I mean you know we we definitely
had days in Vietnam where we were just
you know [__] hang out in the city
and just you know maybe go have a bite
to eat and just no physical activities
whatsoever but I think what was really
fun about this trip is that there was
kind of like a mixture of everything
like you know some days where we're just
like full on all day activity and then
there were some days where I was just
[__] sleeping you know like and not
doing anything going to the pool having
a drink at the you know at the bar or
whatever yeah
yeah that's that's the vacation I want
this video is sponsored by expressvpn so
we all know how expressvpn protects your
privacy and security online right but
here's something you might not know
gentlemen you can also use expressvpn to
unlock movies and shows that are only
available in other countries you can't
this whole week I've been using
especially began to binge the office on
UK Netflix I just fire up the expressvpn
app change my location to the UK reflect
Netflix and that's it are you telling me
that expressvpn lets you control where
you want the site thinks you're located
so you can choose from 100 different
countries so you can watch stuff like
parasite on Korean Netflix but it's not
just Netflix Channel and expressvpn
works with any streaming service Hulu
BBC iPlayer YouTube you name it there
are hundreds of vpns out there but the
reason we use expressvpn to watch shows
is because it's ridiculously fast but
Joey like I want to use expressvpn more
on my phone but I don't know if they can
sort that out you'll be happy to know
that expressvpn also works on all of
your devices phones media consoles Smart
TVs and so much more so you can watch
what you want on the big screen or on
the go so if you want to get access to
hundreds of new shows go to
expressvpn.com taste right now and you
can get an extra three months of special
CPN or three damn that's expressvpn.com
trashchase expressvpn
to learn more
after after all this crap we just did
yeah so tell me about your uh guys ax
experience how was it well yeah so I
went to LA like a week before you right
because you actually had my charity
event um
thank you thank you
um yeah that went well it went great I
mean I was like shooting myself a week
before because I was like okay this is
like real yeah
and I was just filming a bunch of stuff
before and prepping and then I did like
uh did some other stuff as well I um uh
uh I can't remember what I did actually
I did um I went to Disneyland as well
how was that that was interesting so we
we had the uh like the super VIP tour
the way you pay like a [__] ton of money
and you get a guy who shows you around
and you get to cut every line right uh
and it was not bad yeah I mean Disney's
not bad if you can skip every line it
wasn't worse wow I didn't I mean I
didn't pay
and yes yes
[__] but you can I think the benefit is
that you can take as many people as you
want on this tour
um
right but so you could take like a group
of 30. and everyone gets the privilege
of cutting the line right
um and I think a lot of well if you have
a lot of money I'm sure you can enjoy
Disneyland who knew well I think the
idea is that you normally split it
between like 10 of you yeah so it's like
an extra and you'll obviously have to be
wealthy as well which yeah because you
know I I mean you also have to be just
wealthy in general to go to Disneyland
it's like those people it's like those
people in uh Japanese Disneyland that
where you can do weddings yeah oh my
Japanese Disneyland and I heard from a
friend because she knew someone who did
a wedding at Disneyland dude like
minimum it's like 400k yeah I believe
that yeah yeah wait for to say 400 000
Yen you mean 400 000 what yeah well wait
what no way I don't know how real that
is me it's like including everything
like the catering and everything but
like you basically rent out Disneyland
for the day
went to Disneyland a few weeks ago she
saw like another couple getting married
at Disneyland because it you know they
must not have rented it out then right
yeah well yeah but like you rent out the
actual castle like the Disney Castle
because that's where they do everything
um way too much and they would like
bring in you know they'll bring you in
on like horse and carriage there'd be
like an orchestra waiting for you like
you know to bring you in and you know
it's all open to the public right I'm
sure all the inside of the castle and
this couple walks out and from the video
that Akito I was just like that looks
like a very wealthy car
but you know when you can just tell me
you don't know it's just like they're
probably super rich like immediately I
was like yeah I can see why you're doing
this because or maybe it's all a facade
maybe it's all facade and they're all
incredibly in debt right yeah who knows
I streamed the whole time because I was
I'm sure a mouse around I don't care
about his name but I'll show him Mouse
around and everyone was like oh you know
because in Japan people like is it okay
to film next in Japan you can't film or
do anything yeah I was like yeah if you
pay to win baby
you pay you can stream the whole goddamn
thing yeah and they were like they would
let me go on the rides with the phone
they would let me do everything and I
was like it's crazy how it's even though
it's not technically the same company
because they lease out the license yeah
but it's like it's crazy how you just
have the exact same thing in two
different countries in wholly different
rooms oh yeah absolutely yeah you can't
do [__] in the Japan one
um which is fine because I don't want to
go there anyway yeah but it was it was
fun it was interesting I had to go ahead
and I guess because they scheduled me to
go and meet all the
um characters and that was that was
painful that was tough what do you mean
meet all of the characters wait you
weren't hype you weren't hype to see
Mickey not in me dick a Dickie
that's the Vietnamese version in that
restaurant
a bit of a sake
they're like [__] snow white uh
[__] Elsa actually Iron Man was
pretty cool he's pretty high but he's
nice being Tony Stark yeah
Doctor Strange yeah she's awkward
because I'm like I don't give a [__] I
don't want to pretend like I care that
you're pretending that you're this
character that's the British in you yeah
I was dying of cringe yeah it's just
like one thing I've always realized is
that you know some people are very much
into like the whole immersion it's so
interesting and just getting into the
role and I'm like is this a British
thing or is this a me thing and I feel
like that's part of the reason why I
have such a hard time let's say you know
getting into the idea of something like
DND which to to be fair I very much did
enjoy the whole aspect of DnD but I feel
like some people will like get into that
role I like it now it's growing on me I
I had the same mindset initially I was
like yeah it's cringe so you're
pretending to be a character you're not
in front of all your friends but yeah no
it's really fun as [__] yeah yeah but
like I could never do that in like
Disneyland or something like that I
don't know I yeah it was tough but the
rides were kids and the food was okay
better than the one in Japan I thought
generally that's my whole tag I guess
yeah
I'm not Disney at all I hate I [__]
hate those dishes people talk about it
on YouTube all the time like I can't
watch this yeah um yeah uh so that was
interesting that was fun yeah got my
steps in there yeah 2 000 steps but this
is why you're having steps in because
you're going places of course you're
gonna have steps in at an anime
convention that's the only time weeb's
actually bought places man they're all
in Japan you're not going anywhere
you're just in your room yeah yeah and
then we had uh so then I was like after
that Disney thing I was like literally
like it was like two days before the
auction so yeah we get set up the day
before in the hotel everyone's coming in
and then it feels like really real and
weird because you're like oh there's
like 40 people here all yeah to help do
my thing and then it's weird because
then I guess like this is my first time
experiencing kind of being
like the guy I don't know how this is
yeah
when there's a question about like
creative everyone's just kind of waiting
on you yeah give your input and it's
kind of like the director well yeah
because I'm like I'm just a guy who does
stuff in his room and here are like 30
very professional people who've been
working in this this industry for a
while and doing this kind of stuff and
they're waiting on my input and it feels
very odd uh but it's also very
satisfying to work in that environment
and kind of do more kind of stuff like
that yeah so like the day before
I was like just [__] myself because
I was like I don't know what's gonna
happen like uh I probably should preface
I it's a charity auction event that is
on Twitch just in case no one knows you
all know what it is yeah but I'm just
saying because you didn't
um the day before we had like rehearsals
uh and that's where I was like oh God I
was shooting myself because like you
know how rehearsals off you've ever done
them it's like you can't like I guess
you could give it your all but it just
doesn't feel the same and you're trying
to you're trying to make sure that it
feels as close to the what's happening
you're definitely operating at like 50
yeah yeah you're kind of like you're
trying to perform and then everyone's
kind of like and you're not actually
like trying to be funny or anything but
then it does feel weird when you're like
trying to do the thing and everyone's
just like
good but like no one's kind of
interacting yeah yeah and then we're
like running through the show and
there's so much stuff to keep track of
and it's all like on the Fly and so I'm
like holy [__] this is a lot of stuff
that I gotta try to stay on top of while
I'm up there yeah for five hours
um
and so just go to bed I'm [__]
myself but like I I get a good night's
sleep I did actually yeah I did get like
six hours of sleep which is pretty good
because I think for normally this kind
of stuff I'd get like two yeah uh if I
get nervous or something I'm like
like I think the cycle of thought I was
more nervous well I don't know but sorry
I slept worse for
um and then then on the day it felt so
real and I was [__] myself so I was
like okay I gotta perform I gotta
perform I gotta perform uh and then we
had like because I had a I sold tickets
I sold uh 20 tickets for VIPs to buy for
two thousand dollars each yeah yeah uh
trip to Disneyland yeah literally
average Disney adult spending
um but the whole the whole catch was is
that like okay uh the whole catch I
guess the whole benefit is that the two
thousand dollars goes to charity you can
use that two thousand dollars to bid on
things
um and then also you get to come and
arrive earlier and you get to have like
a VIP lunch with all the other people
and me and we all had a lunch together
for like two hours and we took photos
and they all got photos and it was fun
everyone was super nice and the food was
great although I was too nervous to eat
anything because you know how it is when
you when you get really nervous yeah I
just I I can't yeah so I was just living
on Gatorade and chocolate just just to
get ready the average streamer died
just need energy and I don't need I
can't eat a meal uh you know I find
perfect for those occasions what it's
the Japanese energy gel packs oh my God
every shoot every shoot I bring one
because I'm like this is it this is the
time that they are useful they are so
[__] good any other meal would be
proud yeah any other shoot I'm like
bringing the three course meal let's not
start till I've eaten a full Buffet like
let's chill out let's not because I'm
not that as invested right I mean I do
care but obviously you've done it before
so you're like I'm not I'm not nervous
like 90 95 of shoots that we do I am not
nervous about like I'm just like I know
what to do I know how to do it but this
one I was like shooting myself yeah yeah
yeah
um were you nervous like did you have
that same feeling when we did the first
America torture yeah yeah oh okay okay
yeah it's kind of like a big feeling
yeah like honestly like a bit more
because it was like at least on the show
yeah that's yeah if you guys yeah yeah
and like on this one it's like oh if I
[__] up it's all me yeah singer's wrong
it's all on me yeah I'm the one up there
like yeah there's no one I can bounce
off of there's nothing I can do
um so it was just kind of like all right
we're going into it and like I obviously
I knew the structure of the show and I
knew what beats to kind of hit but still
on the day there's gonna be so much
happening and there's no way to rehearse
the whole thing and like literally one
hour before I really start [__]
[__] myself and then I see them on
the starting soon screen and people are
still asking me for stuff and and then
everyone's turning up like you're
turning up yeah the content creators are
turning up and I'm like is this person
here they're gonna be here because
they're going up first and then people
were changing stuff because you know you
know content creators are like yeah
someone's like hey can I go on earlier
and then someone's like hey I'm not
turning up and I'm like oh [__] can I
stay on top of all of this yeah uh but
yeah the show started I was definitely
nervous the first 10 15 minutes and then
kind of went into it and it went pretty
well I think uh yeah it went pretty well
I think it went more than pretty well
thank you thank you thank you I
appreciate it God I definitely got into
this you just [__] killed O'Connor
I'm just gonna say I mean I was there so
you know you can't say it himself so you
need someone else to say yeah as a
person is when you do this stuff you
never want to think like if you think
like I killed it or like I did the best
I could have ever done you're like
there's no room then you can't improve
yeah yeah because I like to think that I
think I did a good job and I think with
what we had and how it all went I think
I did pretty damn good yeah I think
that's the best mind yeah but I think
there's definitely ways we can improve
it I mean I think from the audience
reflective because I was in the audience
it was just a lot of it was generally
just a lot of fun uh seeing just a live
auction this is technically the first
auction I've ever been in my life and
it's the first auction that I've ever
been in as well so I like before the
show like Sydney deal was like looking
at like the list we weren't planning on
bidding at all and then Sydney just saw
like the Smosh conference I just like
like I saw her light I saw her eyes like
open up like I had like a [__] sweat
like coming down because I'm like Cindy
are you planning to bid on this and
she's like yeah I am planning to build
on this and then I was like okay we're
gonna try going for it for uh I'm gonna
try to go for it so I had I had an idea
going in like of our general budget
which was going to be about like I don't
know how much items were going to be
sold for I was gonna think I was
thinking that they were gonna be sold
for like a thousand two thousand did you
have like a like a idea how much item
would be sold for I thought stuff would
roughly go in the three to five range
right kind of on average did yeah and
then the big stuff went for quite a long
yeah yeah I I expected like the big
stuff to go for quite a lot so I was
like uh okay let's let's take off let's
take a mental budget Sydney was just
like so Trigger Happy on the day because
it was like such a good vibe she was
like should I bid on this and I'm like
no no
and then uh so the Smosh Comics uh come
up and I like At first like she starts
bidding and she we go up all the way to
like 2000 or 2500 or something and
that's where she starts hesitating and
I'm like all right I gotta be a good
husband here I was like Sydney I will
pay for half of it oh and so I take it
and then we I uh we start getting into a
bidding war with like Carl Jacobs I
think Jacobs is behind him yeah Carl
Jacobs is behind me and I like start
bidding and then he starts bidding and I
remember like halfway through I like
turn around I give him like the biggest
evils like you [__] this is mine
I
I feel bad because after I look back he
just stops bidding
so we so we got up to like 4 000 and
then we're up against like
someone online and here's the thing I
did not know if like the person online
was just like kind of like trolling just
to see how high the bids would get so
every time we increase the biddy really
like they would increase it by fifty
dollars uh and like like the gears were
just turning in my head and I was like
uh I remember we got we got up to like
four thousand five hundred dollars yeah
and I was like Sydney just go to five
thousand just go to work just just go to
five five thousand seal the deal yeah
let's let's stop this like [__]
little you know [__] playing around
let's go to five thousand and we go up
to five thousand they go like five
thousand like 100
50. I was like all right that's it this
is it they they're awesome you didn't
get it yeah so we did not get it I
really wanted you guys to get it because
I thought it'd be a really good moment
but you know that's how it is right yeah
it's it's how it is and that was one of
the things in the show that like I think
was kind of tough to manage because it's
like we need the online bids there
because they help you know raise more
money yeah and it helps people at their
home yeah maybe a fat stack so you can't
be there yeah exactly uh donate but uh
also had it so that people could enter
their Max bid because it's pretty common
on auction websites you put your max bid
it so it stops it from people like you
know because sometimes it buffers or
sometimes your internet cuts out yeah
sometimes the web page doesn't loaded so
that's there for that
but I think next time isn't this one
thing that I was talking to them about
right after the show I was like hey I
think the it's super anti-climactic when
like someone in the audience be like
raises it by like a thousand and
everyone goes like whoa and then online
it's like 50 more yeah but obviously
it's because they're trying to not scam
people but also I think doing it next
time so it's more incremental so that
like when it gets to 5000 it would
automatically switch that it has to go
up by 200 every time yeah
um kind of kind of like poker blinds you
know yeah exactly like a bag of blind
yeah yeah exactly because I mean that
would make it at least so when these
trickling online things come in yeah at
least it's not especially if like
because the only time it was ever kind
of like a bit hard to be the host was
when there was two online bidders
battling yeah because there was and I
was relying on the actors who are great
the actors were so [__] funny oh they
were great some of them were having like
a bit too much fun they were like so
yeah so we hired actors uh to represent
the online bidders okay okay and there
were these four actors and they were so
[__] funny uh and and I later Hood
after the show they were all they were
all like joking because uh I I think uh
Point Crow and and then stanzanite were
sitting behind them and they were all
joking being like nah my guy he's
[__] Rich he's like they were like
[__] they were like bantering the
whole time and then whenever there was a
bid they would be like No 5 000 it was
so funny yes it was such a good idea
that was great yeah because that was
that originally I was like okay I guess
that could work when they pitched the
idea to me I was like that's interesting
and I'm so glad that they convinced me
to do it because it was such a good idea
it was such a good good [__] uh move
to make the online bids uh be
interesting uh but yeah it went really
well I think uh and we had that really
hype moment with that guy uh where he
the last second he bid on it but then it
[__] everything up yeah so there was a
moment in the show where this guy was
bidding it was like 14 000 for some
German uh some exclusive German like
Prince stuff for his card game yeah uh
called Grotto beast and there's a huge
German fan in the audience and uh the
way that it had to work is that the
moment I would say I think I would give
the cue to the staff saying all right
we're closing it out and then I do three
two one right but obviously the none of
the people in the audience understood
what that they don't know it's a cue but
I'm queuing to the staff that I'm close
the online bids so they'd closed the the
auction for this item
as I was doing the three two one and
then this guy on the audience goes all
right this because I thought it was a
gavel I thought it was a knocking on me
it's kind of tough because they I I
think they needed to close the online
bids before I started the gavel because
otherwise it could theoretically come in
on three and they wouldn't be able to
relay that information to me yeah
so they would close it so it was kind of
thing but I'm sure we can think of a
better way of doing it next time uh so
then he said like 15 000 and everyone
lost their mind it was great uh but
right before I hit it and then we were
like okay you've got it but then it
turned out they closed it and actually
let the guy before win and then we had
to we they asked the guy online they're
like hey do you want a better 15 and he
said no so the guy did get it in the end
right right it's a good moment I'm glad
it panned out that way uh it was super
hype it was a fun moment that was a
really fun moment agreement oh yeah uh
and then Chris finally sold his big
mouth I saw that which is so [__]
funny because Chris is like I'm so happy
to give this away it's like that he's
been finding he's been looking for a
reason to get ready I can't wait to have
him on well because we'll have a monsoon
and I can't wait to ask him about it I
actually wanted off our gift yeah I
actually wanted to win it so I could
give it back
because I thought it'd be so funny that
Chris couldn't escape this yeah yeah I
guess sort of like eight thousand
dollars oh nice yeah you already wanted
that and uh yeah it was great it was
just such a good show and at the end of
it it was like oh man I was so emotional
it's so hard not to like tear up because
it was just like you have all these pent
up emotions and then you're just like
trying not to cry but I couldn't help
myself yeah [__] there's so much work
went into it yeah man and it went really
well and I would like to do it again I
think it'd be fun to do it again yeah
so yeah I mean that was just great and
that was like that was like the for me
that was like the main trip part of the
trip yeah and I was like oh [__] I gotta
do ax right now
uh but ax is great as well I mean
actually but that was like definitely
for me that was what I was kind of like
[__] nervous about the whole time
yeah I mean you uh you put so much work
into this like yeah months and months
super proud now yeah super proud of you
yeah thank you thank you it's a great
time yeah and then ax was I mean I don't
really have too much to say about X ax
is just your normal kind of like ax
experience except this time we tried
building a booth and seeing what yeah
yeah we had we had a massive booth and
it was it was like it was fated right
because I looked at where our booth was
and I looked around and in one corner I
see fate go and in the other corner
right opposite I see Hoya first I was
like
I'm standing with the Giants
I was like this is uh my entire career
has built up to this moment I have built
roof starting next to fate go and Hoyer
my entire career is in one room
so yeah we were next to the uh anaplex
Faygo and the Royal verse Booth
um and honestly like
Booth experience was pretty [__] good
you know I think everyone enjoyed it uh
everyone enjoyed okay first off uh first
thing I've I think we've realized claw
machines uh [__] [__] hell holy
[__] okay so yeah we sort of preface
we're absolutely losing money on the
spirit yeah this booth is crazy yeah so
please buy the merch yeah please imagine
how imagine how I feel I wasn't even
there and I'm losing money
so yeah we had a bunch of cool
attractions and I guess because when you
do these kind of boosts in this scale
and this company's coming and helping
there's always going to be so much
miscommunication uh you try not to have
that obviously and you try and work
towards it but there was a whole lot of
hiccups and stuff yeah and we rented
these claw machines because I thought we
we should really have claw machines yeah
because it's on Brands yeah it's on
Brandon and it's fun it's interactive
people can you know go and do it and
everyone knows claw machines are a great
scam so we would make money however we
did not make any [__] money so what
first of all someone someone got scammed
and it was us so okay first of all to
rent I think it's fine to say this yeah
because they totally scammed us uh
everything's cameras but so right
renting four claw machines is as
expensive nearly as just buying four
kilometers yes yeah it was twenty
thousand dollars to rent four claw
machines for four days that is insane
that means five thousand dollars to rent
a claw machine for four days when you
could just buy the same thing for like
six that's more than a thousand dollars
a day yeah yeah a great method
but there it is yeah yeah it's [__]
450 a day yeah so like and there's no
shot we were like making money on these
claw machines but we thought it would be
fun yeah um and then we were like all
right well let's let's make it so that
you can you can win some exclusive stuff
in it uh and I guess there was just
something that happened in like I guess
uh the the price to play the claw
machine did not equate to the prizes you
would get and by what I mean by that is
that you could pay five bucks and get
three tokens which I think is supposed
to be one or something it wasn't
supposed to be that so you get three
turns and this call was definitely op
you would win every single time if you
lined it up it was impossible to lose it
just paid a win yeah whereas normal
claws would pick it up and drop this was
like the [__] grip of Zeus it would
not let go and so you would people there
was dudes lining up buying like a [__]
ton of tokens and just farming winning
everything and then I think they were
just either giving it away or selling it
all right because the stuff you would
get was worth more than what you paid
yeah
and even if we sold it at that price we
would lose money it was free money yeah
yeah that was that was kind of a like a
bit of a mess but I think it was fun on
top of like how much we pay to rent them
I think two of them just broke yeah two
of them just didn't work yeah and it's
like what the [__] is the point of
having this yeah we're a lot of rant
about that right okay yeah so uh lesson
learned don't rent claw machines yeah
buy them this podcast is brought to you
by cash app with tools for saving and
spending it's the best place for you to
level up your money and glow up your
life Connie you still haven't paid me
back for that meal in L.A what's going
on man well gone luckily with cash app
it's super easy to pay you back all it
takes to pay someone is their phone
number email or their cash tag you can
even scan their QR code straight from
the app that's it that's it guys you get
money very soon not only that but you
can keep track of your coin by seeing
your balance updated immediately so you
always know when a payment went through
and you can get exclusive discounts with
cash app pay and cash card finally I can
track all of my spendings actually I
don't want to do that hahaha it's a
faster simpler way to bank without so
many fees guys as a Nissan fan you know
I love leveling up in my life like my
favorite isakai protagonist don't love
Joey this is a serious thing okay okay
and like my favorite Easter card
protagonist cash up helps me level up in
managing my money so if you want to
level up your life like gone you gotta
level up your money so download cash app
in the app store or Google play with the
link in the description below with no
hidden fees and a free to order debit
card it feels like a cheat code for your
finances back to the video before
someone says oh why did you put like a
claw machines or Gadget machine so in
order to get like it's all to do with
like the rules of an expo like Anime
Expo itself so if you want uh and like a
booth there right depending on where you
are you need to meet certain requisites
about how much space that Booth takes
and what's going to be in that Booth so
to be in the entertainment Hall a
certain percentage of the your booth has
to be interactive yeah so there's two
holes the main uh LA Convention Center
yeah one of them is kind of like a
bigger entertainment Hall and there's a
lot more room and it's a bit nicer and
the exhibition Hall was just people
selling stuff which is yeah which is
kind of like the main hall sorry I'm
burping sorry that's that's why we not
only had the claw machines there but we
also had the replica setup like this
setup yeah the cardboard cutouts which
were like popping off from what I saw
yeah I'm so glad because I think they
like 90 of the photos I got sent to me
were just people
yeah because people people told I think
they were like hey what do you think
about carpet cutouts I remember being
like we should make them [__] up yeah
it would be funny and I'm so glad we did
it was a great idea
um and uh yeah yeah so we had to we had
to put some stuff in it and then we had
the giant gatcher machine which we
thought would be fun yeah but the Casual
machine was like it was kind of like
messed up it just didn't work properly
um but we did give away some of the set
so the Aquila bike's gone yeah like
Goku's gone like Goku is gone as well
and I think the fake Statue after dark
is gone would give those away to people
at ax yep and so shout out to those
people I'm sure they were very happy
yeah you got the SSR pools man what can
I say you got a piece of trash taste law
yeah yeah yeah but I just learned that
it was ungodly expensive to run a booth
at ax his ungodly expensive please buy
the merch again please go to
trashtaste.com in the description
it looks fire okay like you know
speaking for you we'll be honest yeah
yeah speaking for real you know we kind
of did this as kind of like an
experiment just to see what it is what
it is like to run a booth at ax
specifically X I don't know about other
conventions and uh like any advice to
anyone or any company that is thinking
about purchasing Booth space in a
Convention as large as ax is that the
real value you get is the value of like
marketing yourself and having a presence
where at a space where everyone else is
present you know it was mostly surreal
seeing myself uh and my I guess like
ourselves next to [__] somewhere like
employer verse and Studio Ghibli wait
it's a dick measuring contest yeah yeah
all this stuff is and all the companies
that's all yeah because like the the
reality of like uh of like how a lot of
these businesses function is that
although they have obviously they make
most of their money from uh us the
consumers and whatnot you know a lot of
these like big business deals are just
at the whim of like like a few
businessmen who like can be so you could
you don't usually like realize how how
impactful it can be to just see a
gigantic like fate thing and then the
businessman must be thinking like Fate's
huge yeah it's Fate's crushing it we
should work with fate yeah because they
and maybe you wouldn't associate with
the booth but like just having that kind
of presence and working with these these
brands or whatever like yeah they have a
booth there they must be legit it's such
a weird business uh it is and I think I
think for us we were just like we just
wanted to do it I think it'd be fun
we're legit guys please please
we were just like [__] it yeah like you
said we just want to be like [__] it
what would what would having a booth at
ax be like yeah biggest Anime Con I
guess we're the biggest anime podcast
which is very undeserved
and so we just thought [__] it what
would it be like and it was it was crazy
it was a little fun yeah I mean I mean
it's this inside thing has just taught
me because you know
we even though we sit in our rooms and
we make [__] anime videos and all
that [__] uh it's kind of like just this
entire Journey itself has just taught me
a lot about just marketing and what that
means on just like a grander scale of
things yeah because if you say that you
want to start a business and you don't
know anything about marketing you will
100 learn about Marketing in some way
shape or form and I say this as an
engineer that has not taken a single
marketing course I haven't signed up to
[__] any dodgy online course about
how to Market yourself because you learn
so much on the job of just how important
marketing well none of us have ever
really like studied marketing at school
or anything yeah I mean we're in a
fortunate fortunate position where we
can be like [__] it let's lose money on
a booth like yeah yeah like let's just
do it because we want to see how it goes
and I think that it'd be a fun learning
experience for us and that we can see if
this is saying we want to pursue yeah
yeah and do again I mean I mean for me
I'm always on just a journey of like
trying to learn as much as I can you you
know you learn that there are some
things you experience that you cannot
immediately quantify but just I think
having that experience of just running a
booth and just what it's like behind the
scenes we've gained like experience and
know-how that well there's only so much
you can learn from like a book right
yeah or like watching YouTube videos
yeah you have to like actually put
yourself into it to be like oh so this
is how it actually is yeah and that's
what the trash days booth for us was
um especially me I am such an awful
learner when it comes to just like
reading [__] I'm that [__] who
plays a video game and I go through the
tutorial and I read what what like the
tutorial is trying to tell me I'm like
this means nothing I'm like I'm like
what the [__] are the game mechanics and
then I actually like play the game
mechanics I'm like oh I get it it like
clicks in and it internalizes itself for
me I feel like you're not the minority I
don't know I feel like I feel there's a
lot of people I think most people like
to try yeah trial and error yeah a lot
of people just you know there's this
whole like I'm a practical in it it's
all [__] everyone's a [__]
practical learner yeah everyone's going
to learn better if you let them do it
yeah of course you will what do you
[__] that's so stupid yeah so yeah
obviously I think a lot of people
some people can can absorb information
better but I think everyone learns the
best when you have hands-on experience
yeah I think that's that's you know
everything everyone can agree to that
well that's why like every job
application you go to they ask for how
much experience you've had not how many
books you've read yeah also I feel like
a lot of people because I I I am in
some ways in this camp where a lot of
people have this idea of like something
they want to do and then they spend 10
000 hours of research on how to do it
correctly just don't do it and then they
just don't do it yeah because you know
you know we try to do as much research
as we can doing like new stuff or new
things on how to do it correctly
something is going to go wrong our tour
was not perfect there are there are you
know for example our tour we we had an
idea that we want to do a tour a live
show it did not go perfectly some things
went wrong with the logistics of some
shows and everything but it's all like
learning I was expected as well yeah
yeah yeah and you got to give yourself
credit if you have any ideas that you
want to do so [__] up a bit to fail a
bit you know you gotta you got to give
yourself a little bit of leeway
um and I feel like more people should
think you know if someone's doing
something new I think I feel like there
should be a bit of leeway given as well
you know obviously not everything's
gonna go perfect they're going to try
the best they can but as long as they
tried the best they can and it's not a
[__] massive [__] up to like a
gargantuan scale then you know it's yeah
it's not about taking risks it's about
taking intelligent risks yeah right it's
about like okay you can use all of this
like knowledge you've gained from like
reading books you know not actually
physically doing something and then from
there you can be like all right I'm
gonna try and do this thing now yeah
with the knowledge that I have it might
not be the most perfect knowledge that I
have it might not be the most like
logistical knowledge that I have but I
know I have enough knowledge in me that
I know that taking this particular risk
will probably work out better for me
than taking this ridiculous route yeah
yeah and that's all about that yeah and
I also don't want it to sound like oh
you gotta buy a merch to like cover up
our [__]
Connor's saying that I'm not I'm saying
this is generally some like one of our
my favorite merch shops that we've done
I actually love this movie uh of course
there's a denim jacket so of course it
was gonna be one of my favorites but I
generally I generally like love what we
did and uh yeah I'm looking forward to
wearing it in the future okay you know
uh
is always just so [__] chaotic as
well for us yeah
obviously like the the we can't
experience it in like a normal way
anymore which is kind of like it sucks
um but also I mean ax is as a con is
just I mean a mess I mean it's like from
a viewer perspective I a lot of the time
I feel like it's
you go there to hang out with your
friends and not for like what there is
to actually do there yeah at least
that's how I always did it before at
least
um and and now I just what we do is we
just promote stuff my Twitter feed that
weekend was just one ad I got to the
point where like I was they would just
send me an ad and normally like when we
get sent an ad like a tweet that we have
to promote they'll be like hey can you
seem more natural I was like nope I'm
just gonna tweet whatever you give me
yeah because I was like I'm abandoning
all hopes of trying to make this look
like I wrote this this weekend and there
was like there's a few of them where
people were like hey this looks like you
didn't write I'm like I didn't correct
um you know because a lot of the times
the the booths are like hey come come to
our booth and appear here and and
whatnot there's one those were gonna do
I won't name which one of these because
I don't want to get anyone trouble or be
in trouble I went to this one we were at
one of the booths doing a promotional
thing and it was kind of chaotic and
stuff wasn't going well which is all of
them
um and this guy walks in
this guy walks into the booth I'm
chilling back he's like who's in charge
here and I was like I don't know I'm
just chilling yeah and he's like is it
that woman over there I was like yeah
it's my boss and he goes he just throws
his business card at me he's like I'll
deal with this what the [__] who are you
gives me a card it's like CEO of
marketing I was like who the [__] what
an [__] just comes in like gives us
like this gives me this card like like
he's looking this way he's like I'll
I'll handle this
like a [__] Johnny Bravo ass
character and I was like this guy must
think he's so such hot [__] and I'm like
I don't give a [__] I'm I'm here to just
chill Jesus yeah I mean most of the time
was just spent this time we didn't did
you have time to walk the convention a
little bit very very very little amount
yeah most of my time will spend at the
booth uh working behind it uh or just
like chilling out behind it or just like
different Booth appearances there was
there was this one moment that was funny
when like the booth was being built
and it was like Day Zero or something
and uh we're like I was sitting down uh
my editor Alan who I brought with me
like to help like build the set
everything he was helping out as well
and we were like sitting down having our
first like meeting for the day uh so it
was like me mailing is like some other
Geeks Plus members and then uh some of
the staff members come up to our booth
they go up to our like stand-ins and I'm
like oh my God the boys are here I don't
believe it and I'm like sitting right
next to it and they just walked past me
and go to like the stand what happened a
lot actually I'd be like hi guys
hi
I don't know and it was literally like
the [__] meme where you're just
standing in the corner like they don't
know I'm gone I don't know I'm the real
God right here
tested that out by like replacing your
cardboard cutout and just standing in
his place and see if like anyone would
notice
it's like which one's the real one next
time we'll just get like whack statues
of ourselves
statues Jesus
yeah but I mean you know ax was a lot of
fun I guess I'll try and be there next
time all right Joey we will miss I'm
missing the boy man I feel bad because
it's such a big con and obviously well
what was I was being too popular uh
people asking for pictures and we just
can't take pictures because if we do it
just causes like a mess and people start
lining up and grouping uh and it's like
I feel sad because I'm like man I want
to take pictures of everyone but
obviously I [__] can't
um but I guess also people sometimes
just ask for pictures and they have no
idea who you are because they just see
that everyone else is taking pictures I
hate I hate that so much no I love that
[__] it's like no because you're like
what's your one time on stream at ax
like last time I was like oh yeah he's
like I'm a big family all of his
favorite video he's like oh when you
spent 24 hours in a manga Cafe I was
like that's I got this on camera I was
like that's that's Joey
and you're confusing me and God I don't
know how they confuse you and I
Yeah
a different ethnicity man I wish that
was like a yeah I know that some people
will use codes and they're like they say
a code word and it's like oh okay okay
you're cool yeah but yeah I just yeah
it's kind of yeah it's whatever uh but
we had we did a we did a panel that
didn't get uh broadcast we did the panel
for katakawa
and that was fun but that was like very
I mean that was that was kind of scary
because we're like we're also doing it
for all of these anime companies and
they're trusting us to it's just like
yeah yeah and like you know maybe
there's a show that is popular and
people get super excited for and there's
some shows people don't know or maybe
the shows that like aren't as popular
and sometimes you're like okay well you
want to make sure that there's an equal
level of hype for all of them yeah yeah
it was great seeing Connor have to
pretend to care about isakai for an hour
and a half well I was like this is easy
I liked it I liked it because you know
we all have wrong yeah I hope they don't
watch this we have our own personal
preference and I've obviously not known
for liking I have very strong words and
then I'd read the thing and I you know
because God had obviously because gun
has knows the anime better than me I was
kind of reading out and doing all the
transitional stuff yeah and I was like
all right so next up we have an isakai
and I was like Hey first time nice and
it's like fourth one and I'm like all
right another isakai gone gonna tell me
about what this one is and I'm gonna be
like let me tell you how this easy guy
stands out from the rest of the Easter
guy I mean I I do that because I [__]
left anyway so this is cool though for
everything we got to Premiere an episode
of my happy marriage it was kind of sick
actually being like hey guys we got a
[__] got an episode of an anime to
show you a Premiere I was like that's so
cool oh my God actually it was funny
because uh I really like when we're on
stage I would like really put mail in on
the spot because there are so there were
like some shows like like happy sugar
life and especially like my happy
marriage uh about beautiful there's like
a beautiful Ike man I actually thought
my happy marriage was happy sugar life I
was like wait it doesn't actually come
out yeah with like you know a bit of a
dominant energy kind of like oh okay
kind of like very brooding yeah
and I'm like this is like how can I how
can I describe this man this is the kind
of anime character that gets malin's
hands to sweat and then the first thing
that Maiden says to me when she comes
off when I come off stage is she was
like you're right my hands were actually
during that trailer
oh my God and I I don't I don't want to
like so there was the premiere of the
first episode of Happy sugar life um
he's like he's like the show on Netflix
it's a show on Netflix
um honestly like generally speaking uh
sponsorship and everything [__]
decide well he would have to say
anything nice about it was on the panel
we just had to yeah as a as an anime fan
uh generally I think one of the best new
shows there in the season uh is by King
of citrus and everything like that uh
that was tough I was I was reading some
of these Studio names and I was like
[__] I hope I said that right because we
didn't get to see anything about this
panel until yeah 20 minutes before yeah
so I'm just giving it to me I'm like I
was like I was like and this one's by
kinema Citrus I hope I said that right
and some of them were tough though
yeah but uh so the main character uh is
kind of like this very you know quiet
Reserve typical like Japanese girl and
the whole premise of this show is that
it she it's kind of like she has someone
she's in love with but she has a bully
right and this bully is like a sassy
blonde anime character and okay it's
like I in my mind I was like everyone in
the audience is going to be like oh it's
just like Sydney like you know because
that's what happens in like every one of
my in like every one of my streams uh
every time there's a blown out on your
character it's Sydney yeah and then
because everybody knows Sydney's the
only blonde woman alive exactly exactly
so the blonde character is uh like kind
of like a bully to this like main girl
and so the main goal has a guy that
she's in love with I'm only spawning
episode one by the way yeah uh the main
guy only has like has a guy that she's
in love with and of course you know
spice it up it turns out that the guy is
going to get married to her bully okay
and so
and so we finally so we're I'm watching
this backstage with Sydney uh and then
so we find out some of the girls
backstory and it's like a sad like
really sad back story uh like her
mother's Dead uh and when
when the scene of like her backstory
comes up it's meant to be this really
like sad scene that just shows her
mother dying oh [__] that just shows her
mother's like her mother is dead yeah
Cindy just burst out laughing and I'm
like God [__] damn it Sydney you do
not have to hit like [__] she was like I
was like oh the [__] comments are
right like every blonde anime character
that's sassy and Bullies is just Sydney
because she the the mother is dying and
Cindy just like burst out laughing and
like one of our staff members were just
it was just literally like the Robert De
Niro like moment and the Joker it's like
really
her mother's dead and you're laughing
meanwhile I was eating chicken tenders
meanwhile Connor was eating chicken
tenders behind the scenes uh but
honestly yeah it was a great experience
and it was honestly great seeing like
just an anime Premiere with a lot of
other people it was uh one of the most
hypers moments was actually when we
showed the re-zero trailer oh my God
everyone was like screaming non-stop
it's pretty cool yeah and I was like
wait a minute this could actually be the
be pretty hot maybe it's pretty hard
watching anime with like other people
yeah other people's reaction right right
yeah it is hype it is I would love to
see more of it watching just an anime
with a crowd would be great yeah but
there was there's one moment where like
there's a character with big boobs and
everyone started cheering I was like you
[__] guys what's wrong with you guys
yeah everyone have we not seen enough
everyone started cheering and I was just
like because at the point I was like
John didn't know why they were cheering
I was like looking at the notes I was
like is there like something that just
got announced or something because I was
like trying to make sure that the next
segment was going to go smoothly so I
was like is is there a big name attachu
is because everyone just started
cheering and I looked behind me and then
I saw the post of like like a girl with
massive tits and I was like oh okay okay
now I get it I was the one
yeah I was the one operating the clicker
so I knew why they were cheering because
I I knew the slide that it went to yeah
and then I was like I was hoping that it
would just kind of we just go we can
ignore it and then of course it came
back up and I started cheering again and
I was like God damn it yeah this is why
we can't this is why no one thinks that
we're good members of society
yeah and that was fun and then uh we had
that that was the whole thing and yeah I
did my panel with mouse as well that was
streamed I think the line was [__] for
that yeah yeah the line went like all
the way into the hotel to the fourth
floor went out to the hotel all the way
back to the entrance back out you know
where this the micros you know the JW
Marriott Hotel yeah so that and then
there's that Starbucks and there's a
Microsoft Arena yeah the line came all
the way out all the way around the
Microsoft Arena to the start of it and
just for this panel how many people fit
in no no dude by the time like they were
all lining up it was already full okay I
guess people didn't know that so it was
it was like a two two thousand two
thousand two thousand room I wasn't yeah
it was like two thousand yeah yeah
um because I think main stage
Main Events was reserved for like
industry stuff yeah yeah
um or whatever it was so they were like
no no no main events yeah and that was
crazy that was a lot of fun it's always
weird having to interact with the screen
and the delay and stuff but it's a lot
of fun and they've got streams so you
can go and check it out there's Clips
online as well
um yeah I mean right now it just seems
like Anime Expo has just basically just
become the E3 of anime if E3 was like
still a thing because every time I go
there like so many exciting anime
announcements get like released during
like ax it's actually insane period yeah
it's actually insane like as an anime
fan I love ax just because I know this
is where all like the hottest news is
gonna like get released about some
exciting projects we could go like you
know like out of [__] nowhere DC is
uh collaborating with Studio wit dude oh
yeah a Suicide Squad isaka and I'm like
where the [__] did this come from I
pretty I called this on the podcast I
said they could just they're just gonna
e-sik how [__] that we've had before I
literally said it play the clip there's
a short someone found it and they
because I didn't even know I said this
someone sent it to me like you called it
I said that they're just gonna isakai
shows that already existed yeah and
they're [__] doing it yeah I said
they would do this I think I saw that
announcement on Twitter like or rumors
about it a few weeks ago but I was like
nah that can't be real right that sounds
ridiculous first of all who cares
because black Butler's coming back
that's all the money oh yeah Black
Butler you don't sound as excited
besides I mean it's it's blackball as
you see they made him in like a soft boy
now yeah that's why I'm not excited why
is he like a soft boy he looks like he
spends too much time on VR chat now
oh yes I feel like trigger are are like
very very good when it's like people got
boobs
okay you know what I'm not gonna take
the credit for it but I was when I
interviewed the co-founder of trigger I
did ask for a season two of painting
stocking okay the guy said that they're
at the build media
but uh I was the first one they're like
they're like they're like they're like
we can't do it guys it doesn't make any
sense the anime man said she wanted
Seasons
don't show my shorts I wanted it and he
was like We'll think about it and then
he delivers so thank you very much yeah
thank you so much Joey for uh you're
welcome of Fanny and stalking you are
clearly it is good it's all used
thank you Joey Joey
anime everyone well I need I needed them
to bring back the classics and they did
so awesome to do one punch man now
please can you ask him
but I asked them in English hold up I
got the map of CEO on like yeah right
now yo where's one punch man
yeah I know I know chainsaw man didn't
do so well
I'll give you a suggestion bring one
punch man back and it'll be like I'll
think about it one thing I have started
to notice now that you know every time
we go to a different country and we've
hung out with like other content
creators is that standard notes is a
pattern
where every time they want to take us
out to dinner it's chill out or you know
have like a nice dinner
it's always a [__] Japanese Place how
the [__] did this does this happen every
single time well I think it's a lot of
people in LA but I realize they just eat
Asian food the most yeah in general and
then like you want uh Korean Korean yes
yeah it's just like you know when we
when we travel abroad I'm used to I I
want to have like give me like the
fattest American steak or something and
everyone's like so I booked out this
Japanese Place uh it's a really trendy
jar because I've realized they're like
you guys live in Japan you like Japanese
yeah because I've realized that all the
trendy places especially like all the
trendy places in uh LA and California
and now like I guess Australia all of
the trendiest places are like Japanese
like Chad took us to that [__]
Japanese race exactly and I'm just like
Chad you're here
why yeah that was that was okay as well
I mean it's pretty good it was good I
mean it's I'm all complaining it's just
I feel like this is
the uh I I feel like this is the
sacrifice we have made for living in
Japan which is like all the food here is
like Japanese food is just great and
then you go back and then everyone wants
to eat at like trendy Japanese
restaurants I don't know why it's like
especially Japanese uh Cuisine that has
been propped up in such a way where it's
become kind of like
a very like high class not not really
high class very bougie kind of like
Place yeah because it's like I think the
whole difference between the Japanese
food culture and like the western food
culture is just so different right like
not only with like the actual items of
the foods but also just like the way
it's presented and like yeah how courses
work and [__] like that like especially
because like Japan is very much a
culture where it's like it's not just
like here's one big main dish and that's
your food yeah it's more like lots of
small little dishes so I think the
Western idea of it being like well if
there's multiple items that are coming
out it's like a course meal so that's
fancy when in reality it's like you can
achieve that same thing at an Izakaya
but it's not fancy at all right so yeah
I didn't need a lot of the food that I
normally look forward to like I don't
need any wings I don't think I had any
Mexican food what uh yeah I don't think
I had any Mexican food because I don't
like you yeah I normally really look
forward to that I had it in now but it
was one of the worst ones I've ever had
yeah it was just dude the fries was even
worse than all I know the most popular
it was like the worst okay um I I did
have one thing I always like the one
thing I always look for when I come to
La pretty much the only thing I look
forward to Green Barbecue yes yeah uh me
and Korean barbecue is like especially
okay I don't know if this is like
Blasphemous to say uh but like I think
the Korean barbecue in La is better than
any of the Korean barbecues you can get
here in Japan and I don't know why yeah
well that's because Japan puts more
effort into Yakiniku yeah dude which is
different I feel like some America like
credit to them the Korean barbecue or
you can eat are so [__] yeah yeah
[__] actually like it actually shock
it yeah hell yeah I mean I don't have I
don't I don't have too much of like a
I I don't I don't have too much of a uh
was it sample size because I've only
been to Korea like once for a weekend
but you know I I [__] ate as much
Korean barbecue as I could uh as I could
fit in that time it was basically Korean
barbecue for dinner for like every day
and the Korean barbecue I had on that
one trip wasn't like it was it was good
it was [__] fantastic but I feel the
Korean barbecue in Korea yeah it's kind
of like halfway between Japanese
Yakiniku and the American cream yeah
where it's like it's still you know it's
still got like the essence of the
American ice cream barbecue where it's
just like just bring out a shitload of
meat and it's all [__] good but they
also there's also like a delicacy to it
that's very much synonymous yeah
Japanese yakimiku yeah yeah yeah I I I
would say I actually from what I've
tried so far unless anyone has any
recommendations because we're going to
Korea I'm going to Korea like pretty
soon uh I've not found a Korean barbecue
uh yet that has matched some of my
favorite ones in La yeah they do good
though yeah there's just something about
the American culture of just in
Indulgence and just being like just have
as much as you want yeah
if I pay 50 bucks in America for all you
can eat yeah and barbecue and I pay 50
bucks for all you can eat in Japan what
I'm getting is two so different yeah
yeah 50 bucks all you can in Japan I'm
scared yeah I'm like where did they get
this meat from yeah like it certainly
was in Japan uh you know because Japan
also has a big import culture of with
beef and chicken and yeah they import a
lot of it obviously we hear about wagyu
all the time but wagyu is the [__] that
they grow here yeah also that's like a
small percentage Yeah Yeah and and you
know there's a lot of so basically like
a lot of the meat you get especially
when you go to yakanique places
especially if it's a cheap place or you
can eat you're often getting a lot of
imported meat and it's like it's fine
it's fine but a fairly in America when
you get the 50 all you can eat thing and
they're like the seasoned so well as
well because in Japan they don't season
[__] and it's fine but sometimes I want
the pork belly that has been marinated
all day in the spicy sauce yeah that
shit's fire yeah look I I get the
Japanese Cuisine especially Japanese
Cuisine where it's just like it's all
about the natural flavor they've been
taken over by the British with like how
little seasoning they use sometimes on
stuff and it's just crazy yeah and it's
just like this cow has been listening to
Mozart every day or some [__] like that
he gets massage every day yeah
Olive wagyu yeah yeah yeah they feed
only olives to the cow it's like how
about we just we just we just don't do
that and I'm like I'm like [__]
I'm tired give me all of the spike give
me as much spices as you can of one
piece of meat and call it a day and it's
gonna taste [__] amazing yeah true
I'm like yeah American American like uh
American Cuisine I feel like has that
like right balance of being like we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna got a
little bit of everything you know we're
not gonna do a thing one's way but what
we can guarantee is you can eat a [__]
ton of this [__] it's got like the
addictiveness of fast food yeah even
though it's not fast food yeah yeah and
I don't know how they achieve that yeah
but it always also I've because I was
talking to Emily about this uh and she
was like uh because I I was saying like
I feel like Korean food not just green
barbecue but just Korean food in general
is uh I've had better Korean food in uh
the US and England than I have found
here in Japan uh and I'm like why is
that is and uh and we're having like
this really cut long conversation of
just like is there like is it because of
the Rivalry here because she was saying
that when she she was saying that when
she's in Korea it's hard to find good
Japanese food so you'd think that by
them being neighbors you could easily
find like good Korean restaurants in
Japan a good Japan Japanese restaurants
in Korea but uh she was saying yeah it's
actually like really hard to find good
Japanese restaurants in Korea because
because of the Rivalry probably maybe
it's the Rivalry maybe people just want
some more focus on their own Cuisine
rather than or maybe it's this idea of
because they're so close by like it's
literally what a two-hour flight from
Tokyo to Seoul yeah like because it's so
close by maybe there's no need yeah but
there to be a good counterpart in each
country because it's like well if you
want the counterpart just fly two hours
because like and you can get it I wonder
if I wonder if this is a thing in like
European countries as well because I I
don't know because I feel like obviously
in England we have a lot of other
European restaurants because British
Cuisine sucks so we have to we have to
borrow other Cuisines but I'm like you
know can you find like Spanish food good
Spanish food in France or do people just
go there you definitely can you're right
right I think so at least I I but then
again I'm not going to France to eat
Spanish food that's true that's true so
there's also that you know like I don't
think there'll be anyone who's like in
Germany and being like uh yes I really
want Italian food right now um so [__]
the German food bro I don't care where
you are in the world I always want
Italian food
that's the one I've always got time for
a time where it's like no matter which
country there's always at least one good
Italian restaurant [__] mad man they
got such good food they did it man they
Chief Peak I don't know how you guys did
it I will admit I think I because when I
was when we were in uh when we were in
La I we try and do Korean barbecue but a
lot of the time I would just get like
bibimba it's a Lobby yeah I swear to God
I've never had a good one here I don't
know why it doesn't go as hard yeah I
thought okay ones yeah there's some good
ones but definitely the ones in Korea
better for sure they're great as well I
feel like my problem with the bibimb
here as well is a tiny they don't like
the beaten bars in La I don't know if
they're big in Korea but like they're
[__] big bowl they're pretty big
crazy yeah more surface area for the
rice to get [__] on I love it and I
like dude it's so good and I had one
here and I paid like 30 bucks for it it
was Tiny and I was like this sucks get
me out of here
oh yeah yeah I don't know I yeah I think
uh but the cream Fried Chicken is pretty
good I do like that I've got a spot here
I love and chinookable it's so [__]
good Korean well see Uncle Bill is
basically Korea
basically I think I took Pete down
stream it's like the this place in
chinooka boy it's dude the Fried Chicken
they do is nuts oh I think I know which
one I've never been there I think Nabi
took me there originally yeah my other
one on like the third floor yes yes it's
all wooden chairs
insane dude I've never had fried chicken
that good in my life yeah I I all other
Fried Chicken pale's in comparison yeah
right that's amazingly the best fried
chicken I mean the best fried chicken
I've ever had in my life is in Korea
actually yeah so I mean yeah
that was Peak and then I went to a uh
Korean fried chicken place in Seoul and
I was like this just blows everything
out before yeah all right yeah we'll see
about that they know how to do it we we
will see about that yeah me and Connor
planning to go to Worlds this year in
Korea so we'll do it hopefully yeah yeah
we gotta get tickets still I don't even
know
yeah is there anything else topical we
can talk about okay yeah I mean there's
a lot of things out well while we're
here no now while we're here now we have
the opportunity so
uh do you think threads is gonna be the
Twitter killer oh okay right no we can't
talk about this why can't we talk it's
boring is it boring yeah it's not gonna
but Twitter's a mess and that's whatever
and I think we're on it I don't know I
do I do love it have you guys started
the threads yet I have I have yeah I do
love all of the little Jabs that Elon is
making to Mark Zuckerberg on Twitter
it's just it's like it's like watching
two children fighting Detroit was a mess
Twitter actually sucks to use yeah
Twitter shouldn't not good I've been
losing it way less yeah yeah it's it's
it's it's such a weird feeling because I
started my threads like literally today
because for some reason I couldn't log
in when I was in America
um and then it was just like logging on
and just seeing people post and I'm like
oh my God this doesn't feel like a
cesspool yeah I feel like it's like the
old school Twitter yeah it's it's this
is what I felt when I started my Twitter
yeah and it kind of made me realize that
I'm fine throwing away all of the
followers that I've built up over the
yes because you know there's you know
it's it's kind of like
it's it's it's kind of like I've been on
Twitter since when did you guys start
your Twitter I think I started on like
2011 or so I think mine was 2014. yeah
um 120
2009 yeah 2009 2009. wait you had one
before YouTube yeah I had one oh I made
one because everyone was like you need a
Twitter if you're a YouTuber yeah okay I
never even touched it yeah but my name
was like because I was obsessed with
Hannah Montana at that time and I only
made it to follow the following Miley
Cyrus to follow like I wanted to know
what the cast was up to you know they're
cool then I realized that [__] it's
boring as [__] and so I didn't do
anything with that but I've had it since
2009 because I actually got locked out
of my Twitter account
uh I don't know if you remember do you
remember this my Twitter account I was I
couldn't access it for like four or five
days yeah because when I made it I
obviously lied about my date of birth
because I was actually like I was like
11. when I made Twitter yeah like when I
made Twitter it was still like well I
mean that's not really old it's still
the favorites it wasn't hot yeah it was
like star yeah yeah so I made it
literally I don't know when it's really
come out what was the year it came out
okay can you check
um yes in 2009 I think I was very very
very in the start of it
um
okay so like three years in yeah uh and
I think this is still even my space for
the thing so I'm like but yeah so
how old was I in 2009 uh 14 years ago so
I was 12. 12 when I made it right which
is crazy to think right uh I made it and
then
um my date of birth actually lied yeah
yeah you know when you're 12 you just
get in the habit of lying on these
websites yeah well of course uh you have
to you can't go into any website and not
be like how else are you supposed to see
the 18 plus you just lie so I was just
so in tune with lying and I still kind
of do it sometimes I'm like [__] it I'm
gonna tell my real ones yeah no I'm long
I'm 50. yeah yeah whatever uh so I made
it when I was 12 and then I had the
genius idea uh like four years ago it's
performing Japan it was like a year
before image yes four years ago then
five years ago I guess five years ago I
had this genius idea I was like you know
what it's time to set the record
straight let's put my real date of birth
in because it was like March 5th or
something is my birthday on Twitter and
people would be like oh it's happy
birthday oh no it's on my boots yeah
it's a fake birthday yeah so
I changed it to my real birthday
immediately got locked out of my Twitter
what couldn't use it because Twitter has
a policy where they block accounts
didn't know this that even if you're 18
or 19 now or whatever they they will
still shut your account down because it
was made under the
um when it wasn't allowed right yeah
right um so you just like self-report
yeah and tell Twitter that you [__] up
and so I was like [__] and I I Googled
about this happened to a bunch of people
yeah and it's pretty much impossible to
get your account back but at this point
I had like I think 100K followers I was
like holy [__] I'd spent years building
this up what the [__] and I had to have
that Sea Dog VA and everything I was
like yeah yeah I need this back and so I
submit there was a few people online who
had some lock and because Twitter
support was and still is absolutely
[__] useless and garbage it's all
automated yeah yeah you could send in an
ID uh but it couldn't be it was so
busted that it couldn't be a it couldn't
be a non-american D otherwise the system
they had wouldn't recognize it right so
I had to ask someone so I asked my
editor at the time I was like Hey can I
have your ID to put in and so now
Twitter just thinks I'm that age but I
had to send because apparently someone
was saying Twitter the Twitter thing is
so bad
it's always been bad that someone could
submit one at this time and two weeks
later someone could submit it and the
person that two weeks later could get
seen first for no [__] apparent
reason yeah so I made like I did like 50
email accounts and submitted all the
same [__] and it was something like the
40th one was the one that got like
approved and then my account got changed
this American ID so Twitter thinks I'm
like 30 something
crazy oh so yeah I don't know I'm sure a
lot of people would believe you if you
actually said yeah so yeah so Twitter
asks it it's such a dumb [__] rule
what a dumb rule yeah to block I think I
think it was something to do with one of
the government laws or something I don't
know what it was it was it was [__]
stupid either way well that's what you
get for learning either way I'm just
waiting don't give a [__] about threads
I'm on it I'm vibing with it right now
but I don't expect it to be a big thing
well the problem is why why don't you
expect it to be a big thing uh well I
don't know because right now it's it's
easy elon's gonna bring down the band
Hammer uh that's what people us now
thinking it's gonna happen it's like oh
lawsuit incoming I think that Instagram
serves a really good purpose and reaches
an audience that Twitter definitely
doesn't but I think people who want
threads would just still use Twitter in
a way and I don't think the at least
right now it's not great but I think it
maybe it will in future but I don't know
I think right now there's like zero
there's like zero algorithm on threads
right there yeah where like I I remember
yesterday I was like scrolling through
it and I'm just like I don't follow any
of these people why are they showing up
yeah I I think I think like whether it
whether it like becomes a thing or not
really much depends on will people
continue using Twitter because I want to
post on Twitter as much as I can because
it's good for my like online [__]
brand and all this [__] because you know
we're like [__] influencers and all
that [__] but like I just don't I just
find myself not wanting to not because
it's a conscious choice just because I
just don't find it fun no shooters also
like only quote Retreats right now you
know yes yeah it's literally just all
you do on Twitter now is that it's just
these like five accounts and they're in
everyone's feed and all they do is scour
the web for [__] tiny ass posts so
they can dunk on someone yeah and that's
literally the entire website and it's so
[__] boring and it sucks it's just
tiring you know it was fun like the
first few times and then you just see
like a random person catching Strays and
you're like everybody's trying to quote
like ratio each other and call retweet
and it's like this yeah it sucks yeah
yeah exactly so it's just nice yeah it's
so negative so it's just nice going on
like [__] threads and just seeing
people trying to start like a new it's
it's like a new exciting thing the
moment I saw like every tweet or I guess
a re-thread yeah I don't know what the
[__] word for it is but like just
seeing like an actual positive rethread
I was like oh my God I miss this I know
same here anyway people retweeting
for maliciousness but just to share
something cool what the [__] yeah yeah
so so far I'm really enjoying threads
just because again it kind of gives me
back that old school feel of Twitter but
yeah obviously it's still got a lot of
work to do because it is still so new
and like obviously there's like zero
algorithm or any kind of language
unbanned porn it's it's over Dude the
moment they release the anime titties
it's over I [__] I [__] tweeted
that or threaded out that [__] I've just
like release the titties bro
come on Zach release the titties bro
there's gonna get this dick out for Elon
sound yeah yeah one one thing one thing
I did want to talk about I guess I
didn't think we'd get to talk about this
on trash days because I didn't think
we'd have a Time the episode it's
already like a little bit old news
because it's like two weeks old now
um just seeing the whole [__]
submarine I knew you're gonna bring this
I mean I had a feeling in my balls I
mean I mean I mean it was just so weird
seeing that whole event just play out
because like betting if they're like
betting money if they're alive I've
never like yeah because I've never felt
that I feel like so post-apocalyptic
yeah yeah yeah I've never felt more in a
dystopian [__] society yeah than just
seeing that event play outs like in like
real life yeah in real time because it
wasn't the event itself what I find
interesting is that it just like
captured the Public's imagination
there's just the way
I know everyone knows this but just so
that this episode in like 5 five years
someone watches it understands what the
[__] you're doing yeah so about two
weeks ago uh I believe there was a
submarine company where a bunch of uh
very well-off people uh and some of
their family members uh got into a
submarine to explore the Titanic and
before I think the irony yes uh and uh
for a few days the sub was just
completely like lost contact nobody knew
what happened to the sub but from the
from that piece of information everyone
garnered that there was a certain amount
of air left in the sub that they could
be alive in so there was like this hope
that while the rescue mission was like
going ahead that the sub could still be
found uh later turned out that there was
a you know uh depressurization and uh
they basically just died instantly yeah
collapsed in on itself collapsed in on
itself that's what found out but it was
in the time period leading up to the of
wreckage being found that I find [__]
fascinating you know because there were
so many there were so many different
approaches and so many different
reactions to this thing that was
happening it was weird seeing an event
being like
this I kind of event like this being
memed before we find out like the the
fates of like everyone on boards uh but
I think it just proves that in some
level everyone's [__] terrified of
the ocean in some way it was shape or
form it's a Scary Place bro yeah it's
[__] scary [__] terrifying yeah it
was weird watching uh uh I guess it was
like oh they're rich so we get to we
they should die it was really weird a
lot of people who are kind of are
interested in general there we give some
people our anonymity and they're like
the worst human beings on the earth yeah
it's very hard because you compare it to
like other situations that are I guess
not as similar but like when there's
like some people are trapped in a mine
and they're trying to cut them out and
it's like I don't know if it's just
because like this hasn't happened for
like when was the last time something
like this happened I think the last one
that I can think about where someone got
trapped and everyone was waiting to hear
what happened was like the tie yeah the
Thai cave which is also [__] wild as
well yeah yeah I mean like the whole
online stuff was weird but like I don't
like I don't recall anything online at
least at that period which is like
people were like memeing it or making
fun like betting money on it yeah like
it was weird like yeah oh no I feel like
I feel like I feel like something like
the Thai cave rescue that set like the
groundwork I mean you still haven't you
thought that was kids so it's all
different but those kids what about rich
kids though huh
all I remember is like I remember seeing
I'm having this conversation where we
had we like me and my watch like a
documentary on the Thai cave the the
Thai cave rescue which is uh if you
don't know it's [__] crazy that story
insane yeah if we were speaking about
this the other week and you just see the
like the uh like the image of just how
far deep dude these school kids had
found themselves let me show you because
I've Just Seen I've seen it yeah it's so
fun like I knew it was deep but I was
like holy [__] I'm just like how the
[__] do you find yourself in this
position it's like so so if you don't
know like a bunch of like Thai school
kids uh yeah like look how [__] deep
they were yeah found themselves
three thousand meters okay see from the
entrance see the thing the thing like 3
000 meters that's like to me that's like
a number you know but seeing like the
graphic of just showing how far they
walked in from the entrance uh it just
[__] blew my mind because I'm like
this this ain't like a wrong turn
YouTube right here like there was never
a moment during that 3 000 kilometer
hike where you're like maybe
I can't remember exactly what it was but
I think it was just like the cave had
changed because of the rain it started
raining and then they realized they
couldn't turn back off for a point
because I pulled in right yeah but I'm
just like why were you that deep in
before you realized you couldn't turn
back to beginning yeah that was that was
what I was thinking uh and then they
were just like so [__] deep in and
then uh you know it was it was actually
like a pretty amazing story where you
know you had the right people at the
right time just some [__] [__]
there's something really happened to be
there he's like yeah I'm like one of the
best cave divers in the world yeah
another me yeah Elon Musk called someone
a pedophile and then the kids got rescue
I love her he was like oh build a shop
to save them the guy was like that
doesn't make any sense and he's like
well you're a pedo he's like
what the [__] what the [__] and then you
know you have you have events like that
leading on to like this Titanic event
where it just feels like all of the
limiters just got like [__] relief
well I mean I think it's it's reflective
of the online sphere and where it's at
right now where people are just [__]
unhappy and people are just not feeling
great the thing is I don't think it was
like this time because most of the time
it was like limited to online but
sometimes this one was just like
everyone you taught you'd like you'd
open up like a news broadcast and there
would literally be news broadcasts with
like a countdown of like how much oxygen
that sub has left and I'm like what the
[__] is this a game show like like
I guess like in the news thing that's
like the hook right that's the story
yeah yeah check back in again come check
back in again it's like all they've got
like twice
maybe they didn't have the graphics and
the fancy editing yeah they had this
with the caves and the the thing they
were like they you know with the Thai
cave I think they had like a few days of
auction they were counting that down
right because it's just like people want
to know what yeah what's the what's the
well the hook a bit for like the news
things
people doing the rescue it's like this
is legitimately just a time frame that
we have and for some people that becomes
very morbid and for others it's uh it's
very helpful it's weird it's yeah it's I
mean it yeah definitely showed a side of
the internet which was uh very bizarre
yes yeah it was to me it was like very
bizarre some people had like a very oh
you shouldn't be acting this way or if
you some people shouldn't be competing
this way I feel like in a lot of ways
memes are just how this generation has
like yeah with the kind of like the
hands they've been dealt so you know I
had like my own personal reaction to it
and it was you but I find it more
interesting just just to see like the
entire range of coverage and reaction
you saw from like under the sun because
it almost after a point it almost it
almost was like self-serving there was
this event and then those people
reacting to the event and then there's
people reacting to people reacting to
the event and people reacted to people
reacting to people reacting time I blew
up so much yeah yeah exactly and
everyone was talking about yeah and then
at the end of the day uh there was more
comments about people were talking about
the event then it felt like the event
itself yeah yeah and it yeah it was it
was such a weird kind of like news cycle
to see if like unfold right before my
eyes but I guess that's kind of the way
kind of the way like the modern
landscape has coped with like big events
yeah yeah I mean the pandemic was the
exact same thing right like just think
of the amount of [__] sometimes
hilarious sometimes horribly offensive
memes that came out of that you know so
it's like I just think that's just how
it's going to be I can't believe I'm
still in all there's some because it was
250 000 a ticket yeah there's a
billionaire
saw this sub paid the 250k was getting
in and he was like this is fine I saw
the sub I was like holy [__] yeah
construction yeah you could build the
sub a much more comfortable version of
this yeah what are you doing uh and the
fact that he brought his son along was
so [__] tragic yeah and then like the
one thing that was super interesting
about this was just learning more about
the whole submarines and that whole kind
of what like that industry or Market
whatever looks like because yeah people
are like yeah these dudes are kind of
wild they just kind of made their own
sub and said it was good they didn't
check with any regulatory uh regulatory
body well they said they said that some
of the parts were like engineered by
like NASA people and [__] like that and
I was just like I mean yeah they have
this some engineering yeah I mean sure
but that's not an excuse you know or
that's not a reason to be like yeah this
this is operational this is fine yeah
because they like mixed like uh carbon
fiber and titanium which is like a big
No-No yeah
because I just don't work well together
and I think this this other other stuff
that doesn't make sense it definitely
went down the submarine engineering I
did I loved it super interesting because
it was basically just this guy who had
made this job was like literally his
entire pitch was trust me yeah yeah I
know what I'm doing yeah yeah and yeah
it worked for however many it worked but
it was like okay well I mean that seems
more like a miracle that it worked and
that it didn't explode before but the
fact that the guy was so confident in
this that he was the one operating in
there is wild to me yeah yeah
um but you know I think that's the only
the only thing about the the thing that
I mean it'd be super [__] if he had
made this job and was like yeah you go
in it yeah and then he won yeah then he
wasn't not saying that he the dude had
to die or anything like that but like
the fact that he was willing to be like
I am willing to say that you just Mr
Burns yeah yeah it's like no refunds
but it's weird I just can't believe that
anyone would get in this hub all right
that's actually insane you'd have to pay
me 250k to be in in that sub for eight
hours yeah let alone in there in the
[__] water and the fact that Mr Beast
got an offer as well to get in on that
[__] that's wild yeah yeah and that was
funny that whole drama yeah he sent it
to himself
yeah but all that all this is done is
just heightens my fear of like deep
water and thalassophobia basically yeah
and I'm glad that uh I'm not alone in
that I'm glad so many people fear the
ocean like I do that's why I don't think
I can like I think after this I've
always like I've been on the cusp of
time with the ocean you're like I'm done
I'm done with the ocean I was like maybe
scuba diving would be cool
I want to scuba dive yeah and then you
just hear like I think the internet has
just ruined me because I've known of
like I see so many horror stories of
like different scuba diving things yeah
and like the wildest thing is just that
you know this idea of being trapped
underwater and having to like surface
slowly at a time no matter what yeah
unless you get decompression sickness
and I'm like nope nope I am never going
that deep I will draw the line at
snorkeling I this this is as far as I
will go if I can see if I can't see the
bottom I am not going there baby I love
how they call it decompression sickness
but it's like hey you'll just explode
yeah yeah it's kind of sick it's very
sick yeah hey gospel just like just uh
but your your blood would just stop
bubbling you know did you ever do you
ever see that uh that uh it was like a
ship and it was like an oil ship or
something and there was some boats
around it and they were trying to they
were trying to do something and there's
a giant [__] storm and the ship
overturned uh and sank to the bottom but
there was an air pocket in the ship
where this dude was just I I've seen
this one yeah and but he was like on the
ocean floor yeah like and he obviously
didn't have any gear or anything so they
had to like this guy who had literally
survived in the cold ass water on the
bottom of the ocean which is chilling in
this room and they sent some divers I
don't know I wasn't like crazy but they
sent some divers to double check that
there's no one else alive because this
sometimes happens and it overturns yeah
all the air gets trapped and this is
video on YouTube of the diver going into
the ship and he's just searching and
this guy is above the water otherwise
he'd freeze and die he's like he's on
something
and then the diver a hand just grabs the
diver and it's this dude who'd been
living there for like three or four days
jeez no no food or anything just like
freezing in this room and they managed
to save him I think yeah it's insane
also I can't imagine being the diver at
that point because that I would [__]
myself I I would literally [__] myself
now I would like fear [__] in that
moment that would have been the biggest
jump scare of my entire yeah imagine
going to a shipwreck at the bottom of
the ocean and then you feel something
grabbed you holy [__] that is the thing
of like horror stories like watching
watching these divers camera you can't
see anything yeah they only see dust and
they just listening to a guy on comms
directly through the blueprints it's
like this is [__] this is so [__]
like the fact that you have to navigate
this and this is someone's job and
people aren't like freaking out 24 7.
well at least they took a dive down
instead of a sob right
basically teach this guy how to use the
mask and decompress and go up I was
crazy the fact that he survived is
insane yeah I think I'm pretty sure he
survived yeah it's kind of [__]
[__] now have you guys ever been on
any cruises or anything like that oh
that's uh that's [__] no [__] no no
maybe when I'm like 70 or 80. no it just
seems like not the worst thing ever yeah
I think it'd be nice if you're like at a
retired state where you're just like oh
I've got nothing to do no time I'm not
gonna I'm not talking about like you
know [__] weeks-long cruises like
that would just be torturous like maybe
like a few days at most yeah no then
I'll be like you know I can just chill
on like a nice boat deck for a few days
go in the pool maybe bathe in the sun
you know I'm I'm in a retired state
right now I've got nothing to worry
about kind of thing that would be nice
but like those like week-long cruises
bro I think I would go insane yeah
because you're you've you're literally
just obviously trapped on the boat yeah
with just like I don't know it's no
different to being like trapped in a
building for like two weeks you know
also I don't think I could ever be fully
comfortable just being on like the ocean
that long I don't know is it is that a
weird mental thing because I'm like
playing you're on like a skyscraper on
the ocean yeah you're like barely like
it's so those things are huge yeah
because like five times the size of the
Titanic yeah I'm like plain that's fine
I mean I'm in the air that makes more
sense to me than being like on the water
for some reason what are you afraid of
of the ship sinking yeah actually yeah
at least with a plane crash it's like a
quick death you know
I just I'm just saying I'm just saying I
mean not all the time
I mean there's been plane crashes where
people survive yeah I mean I'm sure
there's been plane crashes and probably
died agonizingly yeah that too there's
like no difference okay but like I feel
I feel like you know you're not supposed
to skydive yeah I do want to skydive
actually
it's like jumping out jumping out of a
plane okay I Vibe with that yeah getting
in a huge body of water no get get that
[__] get that [__] away no because like
there's like so many things like
I do like watching
watching uh videos of Just massive waves
hitting oil rigs [__] crazy oh yeah
because you just realized the amount of
energy that's just like encapsulated a
cruise ship isn't going to go through
that [__] they'll be like we might
expect
that's what they said about the Titanic
Joey Unsinkable yeah
[__] you're right what I'm running is
that just you should just stay off the
ocean gone yeah I just should just stay
off the ocean really ironic you it's the
fact that you used to live near a body
of water like your whole life okay I
love beaches I just hate the ocean
I love seeing the ocean the ocean is
there to be seen and not be trodden fair
enough yeah I mean have you heard about
like rogue waves and [__] like that yeah
yeah I've seen that yeah what's that
like I I okay as much as I fear the
ocean I do genuinely find it fascinating
to like read about this is there's a
concept that waves should only be as big
as they you know like they recorded it
um but there's been like accounts and
they've recorded these anomaly waves
that are like giggle waves right yeah
like one giant not not a tsunami not
caused by a number
waves these giant [__] waves that are
like 20 times or ten times the height of
the note what the wave should be yeah
right we're like like like these are
like life-ending waves yeah and I don't
think there is a scientific explanation
for them or a pro a proper scientific
explanation for them yeah right but yeah
to go on what Connor said like it was it
was like calculated years ago this is
the highest height a wave can possibly
be be by science you know that's that's
what scientists said and then you know
you had these accounts of like Sailors
who have just been like I've encountered
a wave like twice or three times as big
and people people just thought you're
you you're a [__] liar you're a liar
until modern technology came about and
people started documenting them
especially in offshore oil rigs and
sometimes there are waves that you know
100 meters tall yeah yeah that's that
have not been able to be explained about
why these waves can exist and these are
called rogue waves and I find them
scared of the ocean I am scared of the
ocean man I find I find it fascinating
that's cool it's super interesting yeah
it's it's it's it's super interesting
about those like giant squids and [__]
too oh oh yeah yeah that was a [__]
call though yo don't tell Japan about
those guys
how big you say everyone else is like
stay away from the [__] giant it's
dangerous trans like all right boys
the whole nation about it yo we're
feeding the family and the entire town
of this let's go yeah because isn't it
like they've only before they actually
got footage of the giant squid I think
it's like the only evidence that they
had that this thing might exist is
because they've seen whales be beached
up with these like huge [__] marks on
them after a fight and they figured out
that it's like metal giant cephalopod or
something yeah yeah
and then they finally got footage of it
like a few years ago and it's like yeah
it just looks like straight out of
[__] Pirates of the Caribbean it's
like terrifying yeah no [__] yourself
scary [__] sperm whales right yeah
like who you know you've said giant
squids and I think sperm whales like
generally hunt giant squids yeah like
apparently like their click is like so
loud that if they clicked when you were
next to it you could literally like
vibrate you to death yeah or at least at
the very least burst your eardrums yeah
and I see I see clips of divers close to
sperm whales getting footage and I'm
like you are taking one big [__] risk
I'm sure that near like those divers
near they'd accidentally seen like a
submarine and yeah uh they obviously
didn't realize and they posted it but
like if the submarine like pinged sonar
yeah it would have like completely like
pretty killed them yeah I think it would
immediately burst like a lot of that
like rupture a lot of their organs
because it's so powerful this is
terrifying and I'm like why why are you
taking that risk whatever
what if they have an itch somewhere like
that what if there's
well that was our topical episode yeah
of uh of the month I guess that was that
was fun if you want to see more then let
us know yeah I'm glad we decided to do
this because I I was just like I I'm not
gonna lie I was hooked on the submarine
thing but I just hooked in just like
because it felt like I was watching a TV
episode like right yeah I really I
really wish they made it out because it
would have been such a good ending yeah
yeah but life is never a good story uh
until it is yes yeah speaking of good
stories hey look at these patrons though
of good stories uh the story to buy my
merch and by my I mean the boys by going
to trashtaste.com as well do that go
there right now this is your last chance
two weeks until it's gone so get it
right now yes not coming back not coming
back so get it but if you don't care
about the merch then you can always
support us on patreon by going to
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us a memes on the
subreddit and if you had a face listen
to us on Spotify and uh yeah we'll see
you eyes next week bye
[Music]